hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the psychologist
Lawrence Kohlberg in his theory of moral
development distinguishes six stages
through which human beings can pass and
we all begin at stage one where we're
oriented towards essentially punishment
reward and authority and we have the
capacity to develop all the way up to
the highest level where we are concerned
with universal ethical principles with
conscience with these applying these
things in a non conventional a post
conventional as the word that he uses
for that manner and how do we actually
progress along those stages that's the
question that he's interested in one of
the sub questions is whether our
educational institutions are well suited
for promoting moral development in the
way that they set up education and
Kohlberg thought that quite a few of the
schools of his own era were not well
suited in the way that they were
organized in the way that they were
thought-out in the activities that
student that students were encountering
the messages that they were getting from
teachers administrators and also other
people as well was
promoting moral development in a
particularly adequate way and he set out
why he thought this was the case so one
is an emphasis upon Authority which
interestingly he diagnosed is going sort
of hand in hand with a unwillingness to
engage in education that explicitly took
stands on moral issues there was sort of
a perception at the time and I think
this this still runs throughout many
school settings that it's really the
family or religious institutions or
something else that should be teaching
these moral truths to children as he put
it the school should be value neutral
and Kohlberg thinks that that's
completely off-base it's nonsense to
ever think that you're value neutral you
are by taking the stance of value
neutrality actually saying something
quite profound about values if you strip
away any sort of substantive moral
teaching you still have to maintain some
sort of order or else you can't have an
institution at all there's a lot that
has to go into organizing things and
disciplining and structuring if you want
to educate children all you need to do
is spend a little bit of time with them
in an educational institution and you'll
you'll see exactly what we mean
so his diagnosis is that whether they
are deliberately doing things this way
or not there often tends to be this
emphasis upon Authority and not on
something that would go beyond that what
he calls justice and orientation towards
justice and so he says that very often
the schools he says the school
atmosphere is generally a blend of stage
one the punishment morality do what you
need to do so you don't get punished
whatever gets you punished is bad or
whatever it doesn't get you punished is
good and stage four the law and or
view which if a person had progressed to
that level they're able to recognize
authority and an order as something good
in their own right but unfortunately
this isn't where most children are and
so he says that this often fails to
impress or stimulate children who are
involved in their own stage 2 or stage 3
moral philosophies which is probably the
bulk of of most children and so schools
end up doing a fairly poor job in
promoting moral development if it
happens it usually happens despite what
is going on in the classroom the
gymnasium and other school settings
Kohlberg thinks that schools really need
to as he says take moral questions
seriously that it should be an integral
part of Education and not just look for
or promote the right answers and there's
many ways of doing this I should mention
that you know whatever side of the
political spectrum you're on there's a
tendency to think that the other side in
education is carrying out indoctrination
in the right and we're putting right in
quote marks right to show that we're
being ironic about it right answers but
really whatever side of the spectrum
you're coming from educational
institutions will have a set of right
answers that they're promoting whether
they're progressive or conservative
there'll be some right answers and
Kohlberg says you know it's good to have
answers quite often it's good to have
them so you can push off against them
but just being told the answers just
memorizing things just going through
what used to be in the old days called
catechesis is not really promoting any
moral development and you see this over
and over again in elementary schools all
the way up to high schools even in some
colleges where students are being given
what the right answers are and expected
to memorize them maybe even give it a
little bit of explanation about it but
never going through the intellectual and
effective and practical work of trying
those answers on
and finding where they don't entirely
fit and then reworking them for
themselves the other thing that he
criticizes schools for and again this
goes back to the question of value
neutrality is that instead of using
concepts like moral education
he says they use terms like
socialization or acculturation or
citizenship and these have been used to
refer to the moral impact on students
what is his problem with that he says
these terms ignore the problem of the
standard or principle of value implied
by such terms why should you be
socialized you know we often hear the
argument that you know it's very
important that children go to public
school so that they'll be properly
socialized well sometimes they are
socialized in horrible ways if they just
simply encounter bullying that's never
punished or addressed what lessons are
they actually learning socialization is
not by itself automatically a good thing
and we have to be attentive to what's
being implied by these terms or
citizenship in the places that still
actually have some attention to that
unfortunately civics often falls out of
the curriculum as things get pinched and
squeezed we could say the same thing
about all the other aspects of life that
that often don't get their way into
curricula Kohlberg thinks that you know
instead of just focusing on these ideas
like socialization or citizenship we
should just come straight out and say
the school like the family like the
workplace like every other institution
within modern society is a place where
moral education should be taking place
and if it's not taking place it's going
to take place but it's going to take
place poorly the wrong modes of moral
education are going to take the place of
things that would be more productive so
what does he propose instead he says
that the aim of schools
other things should be as he puts it
personal development towards more
complex ways of reasoning and this is
embodied in those six stages that he has
or levels level one is very primitive
moral reasoning and then again that is
where we all begin as children
punishment and a reward but eventually
we can move past that to the second
level we can start to value other
people's desires much more
instrumentally we can start carrying out
more complex practical reasoning we can
start explaining ourselves in terms that
refer to a wider moral universe level 3
where we start to actually care about
what other people think and feel and how
they're being affected and whether they
like us
that's an advance that is a stage that
many people never actually attain but
just learn to fake but to actually
attain it is some sort of achievement
it's a moral development and so Kohlberg
thinks that schools ought to be
promoting this all the way up to the
highest level he calls this a
qualitative transformation of the form
in the form of the child's thought or
action and what does that mean
it means that the child as they're
making choices as they're engaging in
action so in behavioral context as they
are thinking things out and perhaps even
communicating those ideas to other
people there is a transformation in
quality not just in quantity they're not
just giving longer explanations they're
better explanations of what it is that
they think is right or wrong they're
more adequate so then the question is
well how do you actually bring this
about
what are his recommendations for
educational institutions and I think if
we were going to apply these we would
have to do it in sort of a triage way
we'd have to see what we can actually do
at first and how many resources of
school
has before we try to do a
one-size-fits-all model so the first
thing that he says is we really ought to
use justice as an organizing principle
for moral education what would that mean
it would mean going beyond just sort of
you might say pragmatic conceptions of
keeping everybody quiet or producing as
many well-educated people as possible by
meeting certain you know standards when
it comes to content or you know imposing
Authority or anything like that we would
in fact need people involved in the
process who were at higher levels of
moral development and who could embody
and make decisions according to those
sorts of reasoning we probably would
need level five and six people rather
than just level two through four which
may require developing a certain talent
pool among educators and administrators
that would be a important project to
carry out but using Kohlberg's
conception of justice moving through
these stages and thinking about the sort
of justifications that are given for
moral reasoning and decision-making that
would be an integral part of this
another is as the students move from
stage to stage he says well when does
this actually happen it doesn't happen
because you give them a class or some
videos or you know a pamphlet about how
to do stage 3 reasoning or anything like
that for those who are already at States
through reasoning that could be helpful
for those who are at the cusp of two and
three that could be useful as well but
it really depends on creating
opportunities for the students to move
from one level to the next and he says
well why do people move from one level
to the next it's because they come to
realize that the perspective that they
have at the current stage is not really
adequate there's something
defficient about it and you you can't
simply tell somebody that that's the
case they have to be able to see that
realize it and then want something more
or else they're never going to progress
so you can't make a whole school yard
full of angels by giving them class
after class after class or workshop
after workshop or doing with anything
like that by just telling them the way
that they're supposed to behave they
have to engage in enough other
activities that will get them to the
point where they can see that maybe they
should shift things maybe they should
take on a better perspective then you
can give them that better perspective
now the other thing that he talks about
is the absolute central importance of
social interactions and of what he says
taking other's roles that means engaging
in some sort of discussion where you're
hearing other people's perspectives on
moral reasoning and then thinking
through conflicts you cannot advance in
Kohlberg's view and within his his
system you could say without having
conflicts that you have to address now
these could be real-life conflicts a
fight on the school you know playground
or it could be dilemmas that the school
itself is facing you know where should
we spend the money you know a perennial
great example of this are we spending
too much money on athletics and not
enough on all these other important
activities within the school that can be
opened up for a public discussion one
that I think many principals would be
unwilling to have but that's because
they are not embodying what Kohlberg is
suggesting here it actually be very good
for students we have to think through
conflicts and we have to have the
opportunity to screw up we have to have
the opportunity to provide inadequate
justifications for our points of view
and then have other people say no no I
think that you're missing something here
and then we can have the possibility of
moving towards something better
he thinks that schools should be set up
less to give all the right answers and
more to promote thinking now it's not to
be a sort of content less open-ended how
do we all feel let's make a drum circle
and share all of our ideas and nobody's
right and nobody's wrong instead he
thinks no we need to help students
actually consider the inconsistencies
and inadequacies in their moral
frameworks and in those of others within
whom they may see themselves so there is
definitely some right and wrong being
used here but that's not the ending of
the discussion rather it's part of the
discussion and so Kohlberg here I've
been drawing on this moral development
to review of the theory piece but he
talks about this in many other places is
sketching out for us what genuine moral
education might look like as opposed to
the unfortunate fact similes or absences
of it that we often tend to provide to
our students
you